aber hier geht es auch nicht weiter job
down jannik liga was laberst du ich hab
dich in jumpgate verstehst hat sich ja
nicht
und herzlich willkommen zu einer runde
mit ich bin dann noch mit der gruseligen
stimme und er ist ein geist dem auf
diesem server ist es einfach so der
geist der mich schlug
auf diesem server ist einfach so dass
die spiele unsichtbar sind
und ja wir haben einfach schon eine
aufnahme gemacht einige aufnahmen
versuche gehabt und wir sind leider ja
meine skepsis leider abgepackt das heißt
den ersten die ersten erschrecker kennen
wir sozusagen schon deswegen wundert
euch nicht zu den allerersten nur ist
das ist die map ist wirklich fucking
scary alter wir haben richtig ich habe
jetzt immer noch angst richtig halte ich
weiß gar nicht ob wir vielleicht
zwischendurch 1 verpasst haben einfach
fort wir haben es einfach nicht und dann
kommt aber sowas
also wir sind beide wichtige angsthasen
willst du musst uns immer darum prügeln
wäre wenn zu der jetzt vorläufig muss
der scc a 10 minuten überlegen dass du
deinen sound auf 50% nacht wie das web
regeln steht ja dass das teil ist dies
halte ich echt schon spät das ist jetzt
schon kurz vor 10 alles dunkel draußen
ja genau
okay ich gehe vor ich traue mich ja okay
hier waren wir schauen jetzt wo ich weiß
nicht wo jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
alter noch mal ein bisschen er schrieb
ich habe einfach zum ersten mal richtig
gesehen wie gerade eben war irgendwie so
eine seite um so verdreht ich pack hat
man meine sachen all ins inventar rein
machst du auch mal was wir was wir schon
eine leistung ab das noch und sei nun in
der inventar in der taskleiste also in
den alltag ist gar nicht das ausgewählte
bei dem txtr store gut ja bei mir auf
mein okay ich jetzt mal alle leute hier
waren wir doch nicht wir waren noch
nicht
ist jetzt alles neu für stimmt nicht ich
war beim ersten trecker vorne war
einfach rechts oder links rechts ist
angelaufen
ich schreie alles zu sagen lasst uns
wieder singen dann haben wir nicht so
viel anders verfahren würde das
unternehmen
ich kenne den text nicht weiter jetzt
wirst du vorgehen ich bin die ganze die
aber nichts passiert ist
welcome to the city was für uns zitierte
das studium
wir erzählen alle nur soviel nachweisen
einfach sterne 14 uhr sophie weil wir
falsches abend halal am hallo anna lena
ist schon so lange nicht so passiert
wir werden vielleicht etwas wetten box
nicht bitte alte alter selber ich lese
hier so treppe diese treppe
da kann man nicht rein sagt nicht wir
müssen hier noch eine story erledigt
oder so alter wie viel volk unfähigkeit
die gar nichts machen da darf jeder maus
guck mal hier und wir letztens jumps
geld bekommen wenn ihr alter als auch
die tür ist das alles nur für euch an
darüber ist begrenzt dann las ihr
barriere ist noch ein haus johnson
also das ist so familien haben
vielleicht seht ihr alle gestorben
und da mal hier sind wieder hergekommen
hier geht's ins haus rein komme nein
nein nein nein nein keine chance
okay ich bin da ich bin da keine sonne
kommt nicht weiter ich bin ich bin im
haus alter doch wie komm auf tour ist
nichts dran
hannes schöner aussicht
okay noch eine rege man darf nicht die
augen zu machen
ok ich halte die hand einfach die augen
du bist du okay aber hier gibt's auch
nicht weiter job down jan ekliger was
laberst du ich versteh's nicht okay ich
habe ihn geboxt dass ein gut dass gleich
wie eben werden da gibts ne story dazu
aber da kam zum alltag gehörten aber zu
gefallen wissen eingesperrt ist es war
weiterlaufen den roten teppich entlang
okay du bist voll durch ok
ja meinte keevill müssen schlüssel
finden schnell
ich habe keine lust keine lust zu
bleiben ja wo bist du
leider kann ich da machen wie wir dieses
land gemeldet wie scary dich nicht du
bist du guck mal hier
hier klickst du also wenn du da rein
gehst kommen zum eingang zum eingang
wieder hier bin ich leider oftmals
nichts passiert heute lichtschalters
kaputt man geht ja mal das gemälde hier
alter wie krank ich hoffe das gibt es
nicht schließlich teilt der puppe den
vulkan wolke electric erwartet
es kommt gleich wieder wasser sowie nazi
einfach mal oh yeah illuminati abgebaut
er ist eine schüssel - was haben die
seminaristen painting eine illuminati
pantic hier hoch
wer muss was dran
das ist okay links links an der wand an
der wand lang ja ja ein bisschen
bücherregal
hier ist nicht hier ist der kick ist
akin ja ja das kommando blog hat sie
aktiviert alter airbus gehen wir zurück
in den gleichen weg zurück ja ja wir
gehen zurück an der wand lang ok immer
an der wand
hoffentlich steht jetzt nicht fiktiv
sondern nur wickie alter das ist nicht
zwei sind alter geht es um alte man
richtig angst leute mein herz ist das
gsg alten schwitzigen also ich hab meine
maus weggekickt war alles schwarz
dann laufe ich es aber nicht und nein
doch nichts ist passiert alles also in
dem ende beschreiben stands länder ist
dagegen kindergarten das stimmt wirklich
alter noch tiefer ja klar wahrscheinlich
über neu ist aber so schwarz da unten
ok
ich sehe nicht dass wird all das ist so
schwarz ich sehe auch nicht
es geht nicht weiter heute alte okay
hier in der aufnahme ist alles schwarz
ich bin ganz unten auf der aufnahme ist
einfach alles schwarzgelb shader nein
sorry leute das jetzt seht hier ist
nicht ich schaue mir meine mich antwort
auf breit hat ja es okay das wäre mir
auch jung bist du was sehe ich nicht was
das alter ist einfacher verhältnissen
gericht gesicht alter siehst du das ja
nein das ist ein spiel geschaut wo wir
hingehen
es hat auch ein geräusch gemacht halt so
sagt kulturminister kommt her
ich will euch gehst du dir einen
sneijder ist zweiter wenn der keks hatte
ich zudem den meisterweg sagt ich glaub
mich ich glaube dass wir uns irgendwas
alt er hat einfach zugemacht hier hinten
ok guck mal wieder aus
ich traue mich das nicht mittels gerade
über mich auch leute okay kommt wir
packen's einfach bleibt hinter mir auch
wenn jetzt nach vorne kommt auf einmal
schreie ich sowie inhalte alter der
boden ist aber weg
der boden ist schwarz man kann ihn nicht
mehr sehen ob alles ist so krank wer
macht denn so was wieder hin sprinten
aber wir können kein spielen könnte ist
okay lauf einfach laufen 1 0 ist er von
clown ist ein clown
geträumt stärker ausgebaut haben hier in
kario hat noch kurz durch schaut euch
mal an
falls euch die map gefallen hat hier
zeigt das ist ihr bauer für die tlk
scheiße scheiße
diese kommt wir haben nur zehn millionen
gespielten wir sind einfach so fertig
mit den nerven was erstmal eine karotte
auf den schock essen ja genau jetzt
meine karte es wird besonders
ich weiß gar nicht mehr leisten kann mir
rechtsklick ich sehe meine tasse und
nicht ja gut dann lass uns mal eine
abmoderation machen mir gefallen wenn
die wertung freuen wenn es wirklich
schwierig halten haben dann lasst uns
ein leichter bei marius beziehungsweise
bei mir und imelda von irland wolle
schreibt die kommentare
genau da und wenn ihr richtig gruseln
gehören selbst kennt schreibt die auch
in die kommentare am besten mit namen
und so weiter dann wenn dann wären wie
die manns ankommt mini mehr wollte und
dann auch spielen und ja ich würde sagen
schau bis zur nächsten video mach's gut
leute halte mein herz